[Music]
generally say
that linear regression returns the under
effect unless the data itself is linear
how do you know that it under fits any
ideas
after taking this course about data
science i'm realizing that i do it and i
didn't know that before
i thought because i wasn't a scientist
it didn't apply to me
but after taking the course i realized
that it does apply to me and i use it
every day
and i want to learn how to do it better
and more efficiently the data science
program allows me to
learn new techniques refresh things that
i know but i
need to practice and very importantly
has allowed me to
meet new people other people doing
similar work
i've learned more statistics and
python programming and how
a lot of different fields really come
together to
actually perform data science but the
data science training program actually
offered an opportunity
not only to to test your skills
uh but also to see what's out there what
are different ways of doing something
perhaps
a better way of of solving problems that
you've been
tackling i think it's been a great
experience for a number of people
to have had a program like this because
one of the things i think that's helped
do
is kind of define data science for
people and make it more accessible
some of the most important things that
i've learned so far in the
data science class would be how to slice
and dice the data
in different ways i've also learned that
not all the variables matter in your
data so
how to pick uh which variables matter
i would say those are the big things
that i've learned so far
the emphasis on modeling and
machine learning is is my main interest
and those you know that have been topics
that the class is covering and that's
very interesting as well as
an overview of tools that i had some
familiarity with but the curriculum is
you know a very useful way of looking at
parts of them that i probably wouldn't
have looked at myself
i'm interested in this area and you know
the data science they developed
very fast these days are always
wondering
how we can use this new technology our
daily activities data science in general
not just
nlm or nih or or you know broader the
whole community is kind of figuring out
right now
where data science fits in in different
subject matter expertise and in the
communities and
and where they can apply that knowledge
i support data science at nlm by
compiling reports
and using all the analytical tools that
that's available to me to provide to all
the senior staff at hand so that they
can plan
a co-only i support data science
mostly when i'm doing payroll and itas
and when i'm helping people to prepare
to retire
i have to go back three years and go
through all their pay stubs and count up
leave without pay how much leave they
took how much sick leave they took
all of that has to balance out i am
piloting a type of position i guess a
data science liaison
position in the index section sort of
keeping an eye on the data science
training program and helping people in
the section get the most they can get
out of that
i've been helping people select
courses or taking the courses answering
questions about
python i think i support data science by
working on terminologies
terminologies can help connect a lot of
different types of data
and in that sense create data exchange
today i'm using machine learning
algorithms to
address problems related to recognizing
automatically
information out of the internet
basically and help
the indexing of documents at the listed
health center we've been doing data
science
long before data science was cool
typically
listed researchers process
large data sets of biomedical texts
images
and structured data they do so using
inferential statistics
machine learning and now deep learning
techniques so
let's say researchers provide a great
example of data science in action
in ncbi we own lots of data some raw
data some curated data
and i'm always wondering if
we can extract some knowledge and
that way we can make the end user
save them time to
look through all the data try to come up
with a hypothesis
come up with the idea the advice i would
give to my colleagues who want to be
involved in data science would be to
talk to our
data science experts here at nlm the
folks who have been doing the science
for many years now
talk to the folks who are taking the
course right now to learn about
specifically what tools might meet the
needs that they have
in work because i think when you say
data science it's just it's a large
collection of different tools
and sometimes it can be a daunting thing
to try to figure out which tool is best
for a specific job
talk to people devote some time during
the week
to a network to talk to other colleagues
in the library
many people doing data science like me
enjoy telling others about what the work
we do
and start small and don't feel like you
have to like you know
get it all at once because it's going to
be a process
you know just like anything worth
learning it's a process
i just feel like the more you know about
data science and the more you use it
it will help you incorporate it into
your daily work to make it easier and
faster
keep an open mind to it i mean like it's
it's not something that's really scary
it's just an opportunity to learn
and an opportunity to to find some
skills that
really could help your your job and and
help you do your job better
we have moved from a world where we were
merely storing information
to a world where we can help others
understand that information
through this data science principles
you